just like the counter of los Pollos
hermanos there's a whole lot going on
behind the scenes of Breaking Bad from
shocking character choices to the show's
lasting legacy here's the stuff that
only true fans know about the
award-winning show once primarily a
repository for old movies
AMC launched Mad Men in 2007 and
Breaking Bad in 2008 positioning it as a
major peak TV player alongside the likes
of TNT HBO and FX oddly enough all those
networks had the chance to take on
Breaking Bad and turned it down as
creator Vince Gilligan told the
television Academy Foundation about his
TNT experience great meeting excellent
the two executives who I pitched it to
were in the edge of their seat they're
loving it however at the end of his
breathless depiction of the first
episode the executives final response
wasn't nearly as positive as Gilligan
had hoped and then they looked at each
other when I finished I said get to the
end and they look at each other and they
say okay we can buy this evidently they
were scared off by the fact that Walt
cooks meth so they asked Gilligan if he
could make him a counterfeiter instead
Gilligan rightly thought that making
Walt a counterfeiter wouldn't be the
right formula so he moved on to other
networks while Gilligan says the HBO
executive he met with wasn't interested
FX actually bought the series only to
eventually reverse course FX President
John Landgraf eventually explained why
they passed on the show while talking to
KCRW's the business so we had three
dramas with male anti-heroes so the
question was are we defining FX is the
male antihero Network and is that a big
enough tent ultimately FX decided to
branch out and greenlit the Courtney Cox
drama dirt instead of going with
Breaking Bad after all these rejections
things were looking bad for the show as
a last resort his agent sent it to AMC
which was looking to expand its original
programming slate and the rest as they
say is history
in addition to TNT HBO and FX Vince
Gilligan also pitched Breaking Bad to
Showtime in 2005
Gilligan later recalled to Newsweek
about being five minutes into his
presentation with the network president
quipped the
sounds a lot like weeds Gilligan hadn't
heard of weeds so he asked what that was
and the executive explained that it was
a brand-new Showtime series about a
mild-mannered suburban mom who facing a
financial emergency start selling drugs
that's a premise very similar to
Breaking Bad story about a mild-mannered
suburban dad who facing a financial
emergency starts cooking meth two
representatives from Sony television
were there with him and he asked if they
knew about weeds they had but they told
Gilligan that weeds and Breaking Bad
were completely different
Gilligan briefly considered abandoning
Breaking Bad altogether but ultimately
trusted the Sony reps and it's a good
thing that he wasn't familiar with weeds
as Gilligan told Newsweek if I had known
of weeds weeks or even days prior to
that meeting it's likely I wouldn't have
had the will to go on the final episode
of Breaking Bad aired in 2013
wrapping up five seasons in a way that
gave closure to its main characters as
you probably know the show ends with
Walter White
dying among his laboratory equipment
with the strains bad fingers baby blue
and with Jesse Pinkman escaping his life
as an enslaved meth cook for Nazis that
episode was titled Felina which just so
happens to be the name of the idealized
young woman in 1959 Marty Robin song El
Paso that particular song a country
music classic that hit number one on
Billboard actually makes an appearance
in the episode the tune concerns an
outlaw on the run who returns to the
town where he committed a grievous crime
hey you know who else makes it return to
the place where he committed some
serious crimes Walter White of Breaking
Bad plus in two strokes of wordplay
genius Felina is actually an anagram for
finale and it can be broken down into
three chemical symbols Fe Li and na
those represents iron lithium and sodium
which just so happens to be the vital
ingredients in blood meth and tears in
other words
Felina is what Breaking Bad was all
about all along while drama Dee's have
been enjoying their moment for a while
Breaking Bad is not that kind of genre
buster it was an extremely serious show
there's not much humor to mine in the
story of a man who descends in the
darkness when he becomes a drug lord in
order to pay for cancer treatments and
prevent finance
ruin for the family he'll leave behind
the closest thing the show had to comic
relief was deemed Norris's work as
obnoxious cocky DEA agent Hank Schrader
and all that stems from Norris's
confusion over how to play the role at
his Breaking Bad audition as he said on
Conan he doesn't necessarily think it's
a full drama you thought it was a comedy
I did it's not well it's interesting
because I know I can understand that
comedy a lot of Breaking Bad characters
die in horrible ways Walter White dies
Hank Schrader dies Gus fring dies and
Jane Margolis dies to name a few but
plenty of other characters survive the
series while coming very close to dying
in fact creator Vince Gilligan nearly
killed off Jesse Pinkman in the first
season and he proposed offing Skyler
white played by Anna Gunn near the end
of the series he came up with the idea
that Skyler would go with her husband
and the disappear on their hideout trip
to New Hampshire after all hope is lost
but while hiding out Skyler offs herself
rather than continue to be with her
monstrous husband ultimately the idea
was dropped because the writers couldn't
figure a way to bring Walt Jr lawn
if the entire family was going to go
into hiding as masterfully portrayed by
Giancarlo Esposito Gus fring is among
the most fascinating villains in TV
history he runs his meth smuggling
business with cruelty while never losing
his dignity and poise he also takes
pains to never let his drug empire
interfere with his successful front the
fast-food franchise los Pollos hermanos
Gus's rise and fall is crucial to the
series arc and Walter White's
transformation but he surprisingly
wasn't originally part of Breaking Bad
creator Vince Gilligan's plan by early
season two frightening drug kingpin Tuco
Salamanca served as the series Big Bad a
factor Gilligan wanted to explore for a
while however the actor who played him
Raymond Cruz had to bow out due to prior
commitments
Gilligan told Digital Spy so Raymond
Cruz became unavailable to us and we
thought man we're never going to have a
character as good and interesting as he
was then we thought to ourselves why
don't we go in the completely opposite
direction and that's how they decided to
create a villain who
a button-down cold-blooded soft-spoken
businessman and thus you get Gus setting
and filming Breaking Bad around
Albuquerque New Mexico gave the show a
vast and beautiful desert landscape
where all sorts of criminal activities
could go on unnoticed but it also
presented in every town us a dynamic to
contrast with a dark journey of Walter
White it wouldn't have been the same
show where it sets somewhere else and it
almost was in the 1990s Riverside
California earned a reputation as one of
the United States most active meth turfs
and that's where Vince Gilligan
originally set his series studio Sony
television suggested to Gilligan that he
changed Riverside to Albuquerque because
the show would be cheaper to shoot there
owing to tax breaks for TV productions
the rest as they say is television
history Breaking Bad fans love to visit
the real-life locations depicted on the
show one of the most sought-after
locales is the whites humble home
although the people who live in and near
the house are over it the residents of
the white house got so tired of Gawker's
and fans who stole rocks and other
garden items of souvenirs that the order
construction of a six-foot tall iron
fence
the homeowners daughter told
Albuquerque's KOB that the fans they
feel the need to tell us the clothes our
garage get out of the picture you tell
us what to do on our own property
building a fence also put an end to
another intrusive fan activity which
involved re-enacting a moment from a
third season episode when an angry
Walter White throws a pizza on the roof
in 2015 Breaking Bad creator Vince
Gilligan implored fans to stop let me
tell you there is nothing original or
funny or cool about throwing a pizza on
this lady's roof an easter egg is hidden
throughout the second season of Breaking
Bad four non-consecutive episodes
opened with ominous black and white
teaser clips seemingly unconnected to
the show but string those four segments
together and they form a cohesive whole
depicting the aftermath of a horrific
plane crash and when the titles of the
episodes featuring those clips are
similarly placed together in order they
form a sentence
7:37 down over Albuquerque Breaking Bad
creator Vince
has said that he and his writers worked
very hard to come up with episode titles
with proper dual meanings on the surface
7:37 refers to the 700 $37,000 Walt
wants to leave behind for his family
down is about Jesse being down-and-out
over concerns Walter thinking his drug
making days are finished and ABQ is an
abbreviation for the show's central
location of Albuquerque season 2 wraps
up with a plane crashing practically in
Walters backyard
a 737 down over Albuquerque as Gilligan
told nj.com it seemed like a big
showmanship moment and visualized in one
fell swoop all the terrible grief that
Walt has brought upon his loved ones and
the community at large the central
through-line of Breaking Bad is pretty
easy to see Walter White wants a regular
family man with a regular job as a high
school teacher slowly turns wicked as it
becomes more embroiled in the
manufacture and distribution of
methamphetamine that's all very literary
the television is a visual medium and
Breaking Bad expresses its arcs visually
in an article for TD YLF graphic
designer John LaRue points out that the
characters trajectories can be tracked
by the colors of clothes they wear over
the course of the show Marie Schrader
loves purple and where is it a lot but
keep an eye out for the darker colors
she sports during a kleptomania relapse
while jr. apparently wears colors that
indicate support for other characters
Skyler white starts out favoring blue
but her palette turns dark when she gets
wise to her husband's other life as for
Walter White he wears drab khaki after
bad cancer news or a personal setback
however when he gets more involved with
Gus fring more blue shows up in his
wardrobe a nod to his signature blue
meth of all the horrible things Walter
White does in Breaking Bad the very
worst maybe letting Jane die portrayed
by Krysten Ritter Jane is Jesse
pinkman's recovering addicts girlfriend
whom he pulls back into the world of
drugs she dies after choking on vomit
after an overdose while Walter watches
her die without doing anything to stop
it it's a dark moment and it was almost
evened our
as part of the Tribeca toxic series
Cranston explained that in earlier
drafts of the script Walt was even more
involved in her death he said she starts
to cough and she's on her side and Walt
looks at her and pushes her shoulder so
she's on her back essentially killing
her AMC and producer Sony television
objected to that bit not because it was
too awful because it would mean Walt
would break bad too soon that still
represented an acting challenge for
Cranston when Ritter shot the vomiting
scene Cranston said that Ritter's face
lost all characteristics and out of that
came the face of my real daughter
choking to death the actor added that
even years later he still gets a little
choked up about it
Breaking Bad's fifth and final season
premiere hit AMC on August 11th 2013
ending with the on screen message
dedicated to our friend Kevin cordis Co
that's the name of a Breaking Bad mega
fan who died earlier in the year after a
long fight against cancer
Kevin cordis Co senior told The
Hollywood Reporter he and his friends
watched it obsessively and ate pizza in
his bedroom there was something about
the Walter White character the way he
took control of Zil Ness and his life it
really resonated with Kevin as it turns
out Verdasco's grandmother set up a cast
visit getting bryan cranston to come
meet his biggest fan Gilligan apparently
asked Craig Asko if there is anything
he'd like the show to explore cordis Co
responded that he wanted to know more
about Gretchen and Elliott the couple
who with Walter White formed gray matter
years before the show started
thanks to cordis Co Gretchen and Elliott
reappear in season 5 check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
TV shows are coming soon subscribe to
our YouTube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
you
[Music]